we're right in the middle of a very
interesting and globally significant
story whose details are changing so
quickly that by the time today's episode
goes live you may actually know more
than i wrote know right now and it has
to do with nancy pelosi the speaker of
the house in the united states the
country of china
and taiwan
and understanding
some of the history of the united states
china and taiwan is important to
understanding what's going on which we
will of course get to to begin with the
big story is nancy pelosi is was at
least as of this morning
expected to visit taiwan according to
taiwanese
and united states officials and as cnn
says nancy pelosi is on a tour of asia
and despite warnings
from biden administration officials
and from china
nancy pelosi is believed to be heading
to taiwan
this is certainly uh controversial when
it comes to china because of the policy
of the united states
of at least
for
foreign relations and geopolitical
negotiation purposes
recognizing china and china alone
although the u.s has supported taiwanese
membership in a number of different
coalitions and organizations over the
years sort of staking out
not what i would call a 50 50 position
on china and taiwan but certainly not a
policy that is as extreme and
reactionary as what china would want
which is to pretend that there is no
such thing even as taiwan
sort of out in the world this would be
as the cnn article says the first stop
in taiwan
for a u.s house speaker in 25 years it
is not currently on pelosi's public
itinerary and this is being interpreted
one of two ways
one way in which this is being
interpreted is they've decided to bail
on the taiwan visit
the counterpoint is well it just was
never on the itinerary so it's a signal
that she
may still plan to do it but it's at
least not being given the same sort of
position and significance uh that other
visits are being given by virtue of not
being placed on the official itinerary
the taiwanese official added that pelosi
is expected to stay in taiwan overnight
it's unclear when she would be in taipei
the u.s official added that defense
department officials are working around
the clock on monitoring chinese
movements and securing a plan to keep
nancy pelosi safe china has issued
warnings uh saying
the military will not stand idly by
if nancy pelosi visits taiwan now the
least i don't know if charitable is the
right word to use here but the least
charitable or most aggressive
interpretation of this comment would be
that the chinese military would target
nancy pelosi specifically
that does not seem to be the consensus
opinion right now
but there's a lot of questions around
what's going on this is a reuters report
which says the latest warning was issued
during a chinese foreign ministry
regular briefing
spokesperson xiaoli zhan also said that
because of pelosi's status as the number
three official of the u.s government a
visit to taiwan which china claims as
its own would quote lead to egregious
political impact
pelosi was set to kick off a tour of
four asian countries monday in singapore
with speculation that she risks the
wrath of beijing by visiting self-ruled
taiwan
this is a very interesting geopolitical
story
and also potentially of significant
consequence because u.s china relations
are not particularly strong right now
donald trump by virtue of his
what do we even call it belligerent
posturing about taiwan
about china rather
has
arguably sunk those relations to a new
low a year of talking about the china
virus
certainly didn't help and although
things have not further escalated under
joe biden they certainly haven't been
repaired in any significant way
the official position of the united
states when it comes to china policy
is not overtly supporting taiwanese
independence but supporting taiwanese
membership in some international
organizations that includes the wto the
u.s says okay we don't recognize
taiwan's independence but we recognize
that taiwan as an entity should be part
of the world trade organization well
usually it's countries that are members
of that so it creates this kind of
arguably deliberately nebulous situation
um the u.s has supported taiwanese
membership in the asia-pacific pacific
economic cooperation forum the asian
development bank now you don't need to
be an independent state to be a member
of the asian development bank so it's a
generally speaking pro-china policy that
is not pro-china enough for china and we
will see what happens here we will see
what nancy pelosi ultimately does and
probably in the next 24 to 48 hours we
will have more news about it the
latest so the latest
one of the latest um scapegoats
for the
anti-fact
republican right wing has been electric
vehicles
electric vehicles are seen
as counter to
big boy patriotic oil burning
fords and chevys and dodge vehicles
electric vehicles are seen as
[ __ ] stuff in fact i've actually told
stories of
so often it will happen
that when i uh show up at a parking lot
and park my electric vehicle for two
reasons one i tend to park as far from
wherever i'm going as possible in the
parking lot just to walk as much as
possible so even if there's a spot right
up front i'll park at the back of the
lot
just to get more more exercise please
folks uh and also just so my car doesn't
get bashed up i'll usually park pretty
far from other vehicles and far from the
stores
very often i will come out
and find a domestic pickup truck lifted
with a
vile exhaust
parked right next to my car even though
i'm near nobody and i know it's an
intimidation game i know that the truck
drivers must know
that i know that they have large
genitals and it's a penis-sized contest
with these large trucks okay you get the
gist of it the the idea is the electric
vehicles are not manly and all of these
different things even though they're way
faster than all of these gas powered
vehicles but the new thing about it is
the electric vehicles are terrible for
the country we don't have enough
electricity for them
and what about the batteries and what
about the oil companies and what about
the car dealers even though now every
brand is selling vehicles and they're
selling them at their dealerships it's
not just buy online tesla type vehicles
so now marjorie taylor green is
escalating her attack on electric
vehicles and she's doing so you may or
may not be shocked to hear this
based on claims that are completely
invalid let's take a listen and then
discuss new deal they want every single
american driving an electric vehicle and
then they have no plan in place for an
energy structure across america that can
actually supply enough electricity to
charge all these electric vehicles oh
this is going to fail us it's not just
going to fail us it's going to cause
blackouts it's going to cause deaths
people are going to die it's going to
cause americans to not be able to
function like we always have it it's
going to send us back into the dark ages
that's what the democrats are doing yep
we're going to be back in the dark ages
where all you could have was v8s burning
gas everything she's saying is untrue
everything she's saying is completely
not based in fact not based in reality
whatsoever the truth is the electrical
system that's putting people at risk of
death
is the texas electrical system that is
by choice isolated from surrounding
grids that is the electrical system that
risks uh people people dying so here's
the way that they like to play this up
they say if everybody today
switched over to an electric vehicle
the grid wouldn't be able to handle it
and to some degree that's true but
nobody
everybody can't switch over to do
electric vehicles
most electric vehicles have months if
not years
of wait times there's waiting lists
rivien has a multi-year waiting list
last i checked about six months ago and
so there is actually a plan
for the grid to be able to support more
electric vehicles and the idea is that
over time
as more electric vehicles are purchased
remember supply and demand the free
market
circumstances will react to increased
demand it will become more advantageous
to put solar panels on your roof the way
that i have
in order to
fuel the grid
battery technology to store solar power
is going to come down in terms of price
which it already is
and we actually already know the answer
and i've talked about it before over
time
we want to move buildings to being
almost like self-contained power plants
that use the most efficient technology
for heating and cooling and for cooking
and also will be able to charge the
electric vehicles that increasingly will
be there now a lot of people are going
to say david these vehicles are
expensive and induction ovens are
expensive and solar panels are expensive
and heat pump mini split systems are
expensive it's all expensive but there
is a plan in place which is over time
with incentives
you get off of burning fossil fuels to
power all of this different stuff and
the building you put solar panels on top
and then you switch over
to efficient heat pump heating and
cooling systems
and you get off of gas for cooking and
you've got
low energy consumption induction
cooktops with convection ovens and then
you've got a vehicle charger and the
electric vehicle
and and we're in really good shape now
i'm minimizing the scope of that change
in the united states but the point here
is
over time as the demand for the electric
vehicles increases all of these other
things are going to happen there's also
a very interesting statistic which is if
eighty percent of all passenger vehicles
became electric right four out of five
you would only see a 10 to 15 percent
increase in electricity consumption
so the the idea that it's as crazy as
marjorie taylor green is making it out
to be is also wrong and then lastly
there's another really important thing
electric vehicles on a per mile basis
are way more efficient than internal
combustion engines engines so over time
if the move is from internal combustion
engines to electric vehicles the demand
for electricity will go up yes but we
have clean ways of generating that
electricity but the total energy used by
passenger vehicles will go down
because the electric vehicles are so
much more efficient so this is all
fear-mongering
it's fear-mongering based on the false
notion that electric vehicles or some
kind of
[ __ ] woke
green agenda meant to whatever it's just
logical
if you if you care about fast cars
electric vehicles are very very fast if
you care about spending less on powering
the vehicles with expensive gasoline
that they talk about the electrical
vehicles are better it's better all
around and the fact that they are now
focused on it and obsessed with it
tells us a lot about the real threat
that electric vehicles uh
uh
put
um on the status quo energy companies
and uh that's a good thing it's actually
a very good thing before we move on just
real quick it's becoming pretty damn
clear
that radical repugnant
reactionary and rancid republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor green
wants to be donald trump's running mate
in 2024 if he were to be the republican
nominee and i have to tell you
i don't think it's completely out of the
question that trump would consider her
here is marjorie taylor green over the
weekend on real america's voice
turning point usa
uh
whatever it's hard to even keep track of
what these appearances are
and here she plays coy
but says she would be honored to be
donald trump's running mate take a
listen to this so what do you do with
the fact that um
as people are starting to look forward
to 2024 i think there's consensus uh
mostly among our audience anyway and
with most of the people that i've spoken
with here that donald trump needs to be
the nominee and anybody else is sort of
a distraction at this point at least
that's what i'm hearing from people um
but that i hear the words mtg mentioned
a lot hello as somebody who'd be a great
running mate for donald trump i just
wonder what what you do with that well i
you know what i think if he asked me i
would definitely give that some strong
consideration i love president trump i
never i never hide that fact i think
he's wonderful that's not a secret folks
i have a great relationship with him i
talk to him frequently i'm i'm so
thankful for him and his family as we
all are and i defend them all the time i
every night
i get down on my knees and i pray about
how thankful i am that eric trump became
a much more well-known figure i i swear
i would i would fight for that man
because he fought for us and that's the
kind of president we need back and if
if he were to ask me of course i i would
be honored
it would be an honor for marjorie taylor
green
so
it's way too early to really be talking
about this it's it's i mean it's just so
early
but i don't think this is as crazy or
unlikely as some might think i'm not
saying mtg is the likeliest running mate
for trump
but
she is the type of endlessly
brown-nosing sycophant that donald trump
wants around him much more so than mike
pence and so let's just not laugh it
into the toilet
and flush it 10 to 15 times the way it
should be as an idea just yet
because trump has done and said much
crazier things than considering marjorie
taylor green for his running mate let's
hope it doesn't happen let me know your
thoughts find me on twitter at d pacman
we will take a break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show is a viewer and
listener supported program funded
primarily by the bonus show
yeah oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad well i'm
not the one facing a defamation suit
alex and we'll talk about that later you
can sign up at
joinpacman.com use the coupon code big
voting 22 all one word
a lowercase to get a massive discount
off of the cost of your membership that
is a freaking predator right there it's
actually just a great deal let's talk
about something i've said for a long
time and now it's coming from inside the
house inside the republican house that
is a republican consultant reportedly
working for the pennsylvania
gubernatorial republican candidate doug
mastriano says jews are not welcome in
the conservative movement
well yeah i've been telling you that for
a long time we're going to talk about
this this is a very very interesting
situation that's going on the jerusalem
post reports jews and non-christians are
not part of the conservative movement
according to a republican candidate
consultant
um this is about doug mastriano and an
advisor named andrew torba
jews and other non-christians are not
conservative because it is an explicitly
christian movement says andrew torba the
ceo of gab that's a right-wing uh
platform and reportedly a consultant for
state senator doug mastriano who is
indeed the republican candidate for
governor of pennsylvania
masteriano has come into the public eye
in recent weeks after u.s media outlets
reported he spent five grand advertising
on gab that's a social media network
favored by the far right the candidate
has also reportedly paid for campaign
consulting from gab with reports that
new gab users are set to automatically
follow masteriano both republicans and
democrats have called for masteriano to
withdraw his ad
from the social media platform torba
claimed many candidates are running
campaigns on gab although he didn't name
them
um this is the most important election
of the 2022 midterms because doug is an
outspoken christian said torba
we are going to build a coalition of
christian nationalists of christians of
christian candidates at the state local
and federal levels and we're going to
take this country back for the glory of
god
my policy is not to conduct interviews
with reporters who aren't christian give
me a break
torba called mastriano's opponent josh
shapiro who by the way is jewish a soros
puppet of reference to jewish
billionaire george soros and reiterated
claims that he was involved in voter
fraud in the 2020 election this is a
christian movement all right so listen
this should not come as a surprise to
anybody in the audience one of the most
liberal voting groups
is jews another very liberal voting
group is black americans and in both
cases more with black americans than
with jews
when republicans are confronted with
this fact hey
88 percent of jews voted for the
democrat
hey 88 of of black americans voted for
the democrat they go oh they're
brainwashed sometimes they'll say
they're on the on the found what was it
they're on the plantation some of them
would say
no
actually it's that jews and black folks
have looked at the two parties
and from the choices have realized oh
voting for democrats is more in line
with our interests it's more logical
republicans don't really seem to like us
very much and uh i've been saying for
years when republicans talk about
judeo-christian values
and this is a judeo-christian country
they don't mean that that's pandering
and it's posturing to make it seem as
though
it's not just christianity that they
care about so when you see people like
ben shapiro
jared kushner uh this guy boris epstein
mark levin the guy from fox news i i
assume he's jewish from from his name
although i don't know for sure
these are essentially useful idiots they
love to say stuff about how
the real racism
the real anti-semitism and all this
stuff is actually on the left now there
is anti-semitism on the left it's
different than the anti-semitism on the
right and i've talked about it before i
don't shy away from that
but they are useful idiots for a
movement
that at the end of the day
only
reluctantly accepts them if they are 100
in line
with the talking points that they are
supposed to repeat useful idiot i know
it sounds like an insult it's a
political term a useful idiot is someone
who ends up propagandizing for a cause
without fully even realizing what the
causes goals are you you're cynically
used by the leaders
and
the vast majority of these
right-wing jews
are being cynically used by the movement
we've talked about this
when you've got
gay conservatives and oh well we agree
about low taxes and blah blah blah it
it's very much the same sort of thing
and so i haven't actually seen
what the reaction to this has been
from the right-wing jews
my guess is they would say something
like torba doesn't speak for the
right-wing movement and i can disagree
with torba
or maybe he was taken out of context or
whatever i don't know that i'm guessing
they would equivocate in some way rather
than saying
man i'm part of a movement that
basically hates me
they're probably not going to just cop
to it in that way
but i've been talking about this for a
very long time and this is just the
reality and whether or not you know the
ad is pulled from gab
doesn't really make a difference about
how jewish folks and many other groups
to be to be clear this particular
stories about jewish folks are seen by
very large swaths of the right wing
movement
let's talk about this very controversial
golf tournament that took place over the
weekend at donald trump's bedminster
golf club this is part of the live golf
tour liv
this is controversial because it is
backed by
saudi arabia the saudi royal family some
of the controversy relates to
left-handed golfer phil mickelson who is
accepted a bunch of money to be a sort
of premier player on the live golf tour
and much controversy about listen these
are human rights abusers these are
murderers this is an absolutely brutal
regime should they really be welcomed
with open arms at american golf clubs
should phil mickelson be accepting money
should trump be playing give me a break
guys
and donald trump was confronted about
this this is and by the way
tickets
selling for as little as a dollar
very low levels of interest in attending
this thing and it was mostly trump tools
there was a chant of four more years
that broke out at the event a chant of
let's go brandon that broke out
all this stuff so very very thin crowds
trump uh gets confronted about listen
these the saudis like they did 911.
what about the criticism that this is an
insult to the families of the victims of
9 11. and trump's response is to go full
conspiracy nut and say no one's gotten
to the bottom of 9 11.
what
yes we have
check this out
you're so closely associated with the
city of new york you of all people
understand the passion surrounding 9 11.
what do you say to those family members
who approached protested earlier this
week and we'll be doing so again on
friday well nobody's gotten to the
bottom of 9 11 unfortunately and they
should have as to the maniacs that did
that horrible
thing to our city to our country to the
world so nobody's really been there but
i can tell you that
there are a lot of really great people
that are out here today and we're going
to have a lot of fun and we're going to
celebrate and money's going to charity a
lot of money is going to charity and
really the best players in the world
many of the best players in the world
and soon you'll probably have all of
them so quite a word salad there and i
would anytime any any any time trump
says that money is going to charity i
would follow up to see if that's
actually the case
but
what does it mean that we haven't gotten
to the bottom of 911 and interestingly
before it became politically
inconvenient for trump because he's just
so enamored with the saudis trump used
to say it was the saudis who did 9 11
period like here is donald trump in 2016
in an interview on fox news he doesn't
mince words at all right now that front
and center with so many people
i'm getting on the radio yesterday and
today is the 28 pages that were taken
out of the 911 report uh saudi arabia
evidently there's reference to saudi
arabia you have a democratic senator now
retired senator graham who says it's
time for the public to see him does
donald trump believe it's time for us to
see these 28 pages
i do i think we should have seen it a
long time ago
you know i think i know what it's going
to say it's going to be very
very profound having to do with saudi
arabia and saudi arabia's role
on the world trade center in the attack
and that's very serious stuff and you
know again i've said it for a long time
we attacked iraq
and frankly by attacking iraq they were
not the ones that knocked down the world
trade center right saying that for a
long time let's see what the papers say
that's absolutely right trump didn't
used to hesitate but here's what it's
really about this is from the interview
over the weekend i've known these people
for a long time in saudi arabia and
they've been friends of mine for a long
time
they've invested in many american
companies they own big percentages of
many many american companies and frankly
what they're doing for golf is so great
what they're doing for the players is so
great the salaries are going to go way
up
the pga was not loved by a lot of the
players as you know for a long time so
there it is that's what it's really
about it's about business that's
fundamentally what it is
now one more note on this our friends
the good liars davrum and jason they
were at the live golf tournament and
they really did a good one with phil
mickelson this has gone giga viral
millions and millions of views
as phil mickelson was getting ready to
hit his uh his golf ball
um our friend jason gave him some
interesting words of encouragement
listen to this all right last hour phil
mickelson teed off here at the 16th hole
just behind me here's what happened
[Music]
do it for the saudi royal family
okay so that that was very distracting
to phil to phil nicholson and he ended
up having to rethink that shot so we've
never gotten to the bottom of 911.
that's really the problem when we talk
about the saudis says donald trump now
very different tune to 2016 and very
different tune to points prior so uh
that's that
and trump going full conspiracy if
you're curious about some of these clips
and you're only listening today make
sure to check out the david pakman show
instagram
at david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show i can't
think of anything that it would feel
better to be completely wrong about than
criminal charges and donald trump
the news is that donald trump's lawyers
now seem increasingly convinced this
guy's getting charged criminally and
they are now preemptively planning how
to handle criminal charges against the
former president donald trump now until
it happens it's nothing okay and it
hasn't happened yet
i've been saying all along trump's not
getting charged and i would love to be
wrong i won't eat my microphone i need
the microphone for the show
but i would love to be wrong about it
very interesting new article from
rolling stone
trump's lawyers are preparing legal
defenses against criminal charges
according to internal communications
reviewed by rolling stone trump's team
is quietly planning for criminal charges
as they wait for the justice department
to make its move this would be
absolutely historic it would be an
historic day in fact donald trump's
lawyers are preemptively preparing a
legal defense agreements criminal
charges from the justice department
as the former president's lawyers are
increasingly anxious their client will
be prosecuted for his role in the
attempt to overturn the 2020 election
members of trump's legal team have
already started to brainstorm strategy
and potential defenses according to
three people familiar with the matter
and written communications reviewed by
rolling stone understand that rolling
stone has reviewed written
communications presumably emails and or
text messages
where it is being discussed by trump's
lawyers
how they would handle such criminal
charges trump himself has been briefed
on potential legal defenses on at least
two occasions this summer that effort
intensified after trump white house
former trump white house aide cassidy
hutchinson's june testimony before the
house committee investigating january
6th
quote members of the trump legal team
are quietly preparing in the event
charges are brought it would be career
career malpractice not to do so
do the former president attorneys
believe everything cassidy said no
do they think the department of justice
would be wise to charge him no
but we've gotten to a point where if you
don't think criminal charges are at
least somewhat likely you are not
serving the former president's best
interests
folks i know i've been saying all along
trump's not getting charged
i hope i'm wrong i will come and throw
my with tears in my eyes i will come to
all of you and say
sirs and mams i was wrong and i love it
now
what is a preview of trump's legal
defense
is it going to be made up significantly
of presidential immunity that's it
we don't know but it is certainly
plausible that trump will try the
immunity defense legal experts think
it's unlikely the supreme court would
allow that
um another possibility would be
some version of what's sometimes
referred to as the oliver north defense
the idea there is you really can't try
trump for any of this stuff
because you can't actually get a jury
because everyone witnessed the crime the
the the things that he is potentially
going to be charged with if he's charged
we're operating in a world where he gets
charged the things he would be charged
with are things that
he did at least partially in public
so how do you get a jury
that will really be able to restrict its
judgment
to just what is presented during a trial
now i've actually talked about another
problem when it comes to such charges
how do you even find a jury aside from
people that saw the alleged crimes in
public
how do you find a jury
with no preconceived opinion based on
their beliefs about trump and what i
mean by that is
with some crimes if the crime takes
place in
kansas city
missouri
you say well let's move it to
the next county over where people aren't
familiar with the crime
but this is a national really a global
situation that relates to trump's
attempt to steal the election
and also
most people have a very strong opinion
of trump i mean listen
i if i were to be called to be on this
jury
i can't imagine they would want me on
there since i've been doing years of
commentary about exactly what the trial
would be about but i'll be totally
upfront with you at this point i don't
think it would be possible for me to put
aside my opinions about trump and the
case
and say only based on what's in maybe in
the trial they don't have the clip of
trump asking for 11 780 votes am i
really going to be able to pretend that
that didn't happen i need 11 000 votes
give me a break i don't know so so
another question is how do you actually
get a get a jury let's wait and see but
the fact that trump's lawyers are now
preparing for criminal charges
certainly
suggestive of the fact that they are
more likely than at any previous point
to be coming
joe biden has tested positive for covid
again
he has absolutely no symptoms
is isolating out of an abundance of
caution but it is believed that this is
this sort of like rebound positivity
there are some claims it could be
related to the medication paxlavid that
paxlivit helps you get over the virus
but then maybe related to testing
positive again i'm not saying that
definitively that's one bit
of uh that's one claim that's being
evaluated but the belief is that this is
a
not uh
clinically significant testing positive
again now the former president donald
trump believes that this is actually the
wrong diagnosis that trump uh that biden
was diagnosed with covid but actually
the right diagnosis is dementia this is
a real post from a former president on
his uh social media platform truth
social truth essential and donald trump
said the following quote
joe biden's second bout of covid
sometimes referred to as the china virus
was sadly misdiagnosed by his doctors he
instead has capital d dementia
but is happily recovering well well at
least he's recovering from the dementia
that's good joe is thinking of moving
part time to one of those beautiful
wisconsin nursing homes we're almost 100
of the residents miraculously and for
the first time in history had the
strength and energy to vote
even if those votes were cast illegally
get well soon joe
um
this is a form this is an outrageously
demented comment if you want to talk
about dementia that's a demented comment
but one of the fascinating things about
it is that unless you're following
the right wing sort of grievance machine
as david roberts called it you don't
even know what trump's talking about
david roberts runs the newsletter volts
about clean energy great newsletter he
posted about trump's truth social post
about biden's covered dementia something
pretty astute he said the right-wing
grievance machine has become so insular
and baroque that it sounds like they're
speaking another language you have to
immerse yourself in the right-wing
bubble for years to even follow along
and that's absolutely true to understand
what donald trump is even referring to
in that completely unhinged post
you have to have been following
trump's lies and conspiracy theories for
several years there's like three
inside scam references you have to
understand one
it's this whole thing of colin covid the
china virus
99 point whatever percent of the world
refers to it as covet or coronavirus
there's this group of people that follow
trump that call it the china virus it's
a republican trumpian thing you've got
to understand that number two biden
dementia that's another uh thing that
donald trump has increasingly been
talking about and saying joe doesn't
even know where he is and all this sort
of stuff
and then three
the voter fraud in wisconsin nursing
homes the idea there's two versions of
that one version is
the nursing homes had 100 turnout and
that doesn't make sense it's also not
true they didn't
and the second version is the nursing
homes voted 100 for joe biden and that
doesn't make sense that's also not true
it's another republican lie
another republican scam so understand
how
if you don't
follow the right wing scams
and you just say oh trump's not on
twitter
let's see what he posts on truth social
you would read that and have absolutely
no idea what on earth donald trump is
talking about they it's their own
language at this point they live in
their own world
and
that is not a normal thing for a former
president of the united states to post
the for the current president
has coveted misdiagnosed it's actually
dementia that is insane but
in modern day 2022
it doesn't feel that surprising it's the
type of stuff trump's been saying for a
very long time crazy
crazy we'll take a quick break and be
right back
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
so we're continuing to cover as we've
done on the bonus show the detention and
imprisonment and trial of wnba player
brittany griner
in russia and unfortunately
the situation itself is sort of opaque
and the russian justice system is not
exactly what we would call fair and open
the prosecution rate is you know
outrageously high and there's all sorts
of history there of everything from
planted evidence to everything you can
imagine and also it does appear from the
reports we have now that brittany griner
supposedly accidentally had a very very
small amount of drugs with her
in russia and the united states is now
trying to get her out of what they
consider to be
an unjust detention and there is a
prisoner swap that is now being
considered well donald trump is siding
with russia on this one again
trump sides with russia calls jailed
american britney griner spoiled
donald trump appeared on the
what show is this we've seen clips the
clay travis and buck sexton show
and says brittany griner is spoiled
and he wouldn't have made this deal to
get her out would you have made by the
way the offer for brittany griner and
victor bout that russia has put forward
where they'll trade this arms dealers 25
years for arms dealing all over the
world for the wnba player and also i
believe a former marine is being held
there
she went in there loaded up with drugs
into a hostile territory with okay
loaded up with drugs we're going to talk
about in a moment they're very vigilant
about drugs they don't like drugs
and she got caught
and by the way
trump loves
when authoritarian strong men
just go crazy about anything drug
related he thought it was amazing
that duterte used to kill drug dealers
and trump recently said for every drug
dealer you kill you save 500 people how
he came up with that number i don't know
we're supposed to get her and she makes
a you know a lot of money i guess but
we're supposed to get her out for a
absolute
killer
and one of the biggest arms dealers in
the world killed many americans killed
many people
and he's going to get a free card
and
we're going to get her she knew you
don't go in there loaded up with drugs
and she admitted it
i assume she admitted it without too
much force because it is what it is
and it's sometimes there's force but
okay it doesn't seem like a very good
trade does it
he's an absolute one of the worst in the
world and he's going to be given his
freedom
because a
potentially spoiled person goes into
russia loaded up with drugs
okay
now what by spoiled does he just mean
that she's black like is this as simple
as she's gay and black which to trump
means that she's spoiled first of all
trump has pardoned tons of criminals
that's number one so clearly there's not
in principle a problem he has with
saying here's someone who's been
sentenced for something
but i'm going to pardon them trump talks
about loaded up with drugs
i'm right there in saying
when you go places like russia
you've got to be really careful about
what you have with you i'm i'm right
there in fact i don't think i would even
go
she had 0.7 grams of cannabis oil
now that's legal in her home state of
arizona it's legal in many states in the
united states it's not legal in russia i
completely am with you there
but
0.7 grams is not exact exactly being
loaded up with drugs
and yet the russian media
has referred to it as a significant
amount of drugs that's obviously not
true she also had a doctor's note for
the cannabis oil i understand that
doesn't make it legal in russia but she
explained that
she pleaded guilty she said it was
inadvertent you know it's like we've got
madison cawthorne quote accidentally
bringing gun trying to bring guns past
tsa onto planes
multiple times and the right is
perfectly satisfied saying those are
honest mistakes here's point seven grams
of cannabis oil with a doctor's note and
now all of a sudden we're supposed to
believe her detention is fair and not at
all politically motivated so
you knew that trump was going to come up
with something like this
but the pattern is
once again he's defending russia and
russia's authoritarian police state
they're completely absurd justice system
uh i was let me see if i can even find
it
um russian court's
conviction rate
um in 2018 the gross conviction rate i
believe gross means it doesn't account
for repeals and reversals the gross
conviction rate was 99
yeah there you go in 2018
0.25 percent of russian court cases
ended in an acquittal
that's an incredibly efficient judicial
system isn't it so listen i i get it you
got to be careful whenever i go anywhere
i make sure to bring nothing i don't
bring anything there and i don't bring
anything back that's my thing
but 0.7 grams of cannabis oil and now
trump goes oh well she's spoiled give me
a break it's absolutely outrageous
one of the building stories that we are
continuing to follow
is the pivot
or at least the potential pivot that
specifically fox news is setting up on
the republican party and on the 2024
presidential election and that pivot is
as follows
if trump is the republican nominee in
2024
fox news wants access to him fox news
wants to be in the good graces of the
administration
period
but
fox
probably prefers that it not be donald
trump who is the nominee and there's a
bunch of different reasons why we could
imagine that's the case one would be
that rupert murdoch the patriarch of fox
news and news corporation doesn't really
like trump that's one possibility
second is that trump is divisive among
the right and that's not particularly
good for fox news because you start to
have contingents of the right that like
the coverage fox news is doing and those
that don't and it's just unnecessarily
controversial
so fox news is setting itself up with a
sort of escape hatch
in case trump's the nominee they want to
be able to get back on the trump train
but they do seem at least in this early
stage
sort of to be taking a step towards
somebody like ron desantis or somebody
else
the new reports at are that trump is
absolutely furious that fox news is
ignoring him
and giving so much attention to other
potential candidates according to a
report trump hasn't appeared on fox news
in 100 days
according to the new york times he'd
rather have negative coverage than to be
ignored altogether
trump has reportedly complained to aids
that sean hannity a longtime friend is
also overlooking him trump is not happy
instead of broadcasting a july 22 trump
rally in arizona
fox news aired a laura ingraham
interview with ron desantis
a live broadcast of trump's events with
conservative event with conservatives in
washington earlier this week was ignored
by fox for a live speech by mike pence
according to the times which cited two
people who have spoken to trump trump is
angrier about being ignored than he
would be if fox were to cover him
negatively
trump has complained to sean hannity as
i mentioned according to several people
close to the fox corporation which
rupert murdoch owns
the moves to exclude trump are not a
coincidence
as business insider previously reported
fox news is inching towards a post-trump
era
trump and fox news had a falling out
when the network called arizona for
biden in 2020 fox defended the call
trump protested it trump then moved
towards appearing on newsmax and the one
america news network
since then insider reported that a
roster of fox hosts and contributors
have issued stern critiques of trump and
support for other potential republican
nominees in a recent opinion piece by
fox news contributor liz peake desantis
was touted as a cure for an ailing
america now there's one thing that's
absolutely true
ron desantis would be a much more
effective
and probably to the republican party
unifying figure than trump
desantis's politics are not that
different than trump's but desantis's
personality is less
comically outrageous than donald trump's
and would probably not anger as many
republicans as donald trump did and
every report that we're getting business
insider um new york times reports last
week that we talked about is that it's
not by chance that this is going on last
week or maybe it was the week before
i aired a two-minute piece that fox did
with
random republican voters right
and it just so happened that almost
every one of those random republican
voters said i don't think trump should
run in 2024
and i really like ron desantis the way
those pieces are produced usually you
talk to way more people than you include
in the package
and then you decide what to include i'm
sure that they came across republicans
who a bunch of them who said trump
should run they chose not to include
that they are starting to spin a
narrative remember that fox news has not
actually abandoned him fox news would
prefer someone else and they want to be
well positioned if someone else is the
nominee to immediately be in the good
graces of that individual but if trump
is the nominee they want to be able to
get access to him as well there's a very
kind of strange mix happening right now
of cringy sucking up to trump
but also mentioning that there's lots of
republicans out there they're out there
in the ether who would prefer
somebody other than donald trump and
this shouldn't really come as a shock
because it's a repeat of 2016.
in 2015 into 2016 fox did not like
donald trump
they were
supporting other people
i believe it was ted cruz they were
pretty pretty uh positive on
until it became clear that trump was
going to be the nominee and then all of
a sudden they were tripping all over
themselves to brown nose
and to get in donald trump's good graces
in which they were for the vast majority
of trump's presidency so this is not a
new pattern but trump is reportedly
furious trump being furious can only
lead to hilarity and we'll be standing
by for that
you know i have not had the opportunity
to watch nearly enough of the alex jones
defamation trial there's so much going
on alex jones is currently in a
defamation trial his producer testified
and it was wacky
one of his other hosts owen shroyer
testified and was
ba
sort of admonished by the judge for
going on air and talking about the trial
which he's not supposed to be doing it's
been a cartoonish fiasco alex jones
lawyer is really weird everything about
it's weird oh we got a call
from uh in our voicemail uh line that
line uh is 219 to david p
from a viewer who agrees that this is a
really crazy trial take a listen to this
hi i pretty much watched uh every minute
of the alex jones trial what's going on
right now and i would just advise
everyone to
watch uh day four which would be friday
july 29th and watch the last witness um
i can't i don't know what her name is
but she testifies about
misinformation on social media and
regardless of whether you care or not
about
alex jones or anything
everybody should watch her testimony i
think she tests has testified about two
hours now and i think she's coming back
monday so
just check that out
i have heard about this i don't know
what was said but it sounds absolutely
fascinating the trial is bonkers
there's video of alex jones in what
seems like a nearby restaurant streaming
like during breaks in the trial there's
video of alex jones
chain smoking cigarettes outside the
courthouse and getting um
badgered by people who were walking by
every detail of this trial is bonkers my
only regret is i've just been so busy i
haven't been able to watch as much of it
as i would like check it out let me know
your thoughts
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad yeah
well speaking of alex jones right thank
your lucky stars every day you're not
dave pagman many in our audience do on
today's bonus show
the house of representatives has passed
and is now sending to the senate
an assault style weapons ban
will it go anywhere in the senate the
answer is well
i think we mostly know the answer
it's probably a no
um j.d vance who is the
um nominee for ohio senate
whose name
donald trump could not remember we've
endorsed jp right j.d mandel no no no no
that's jd vance jd vance running against
democrat tim ryan who i want to see win
j.d vance is now saying
even if if a woman is in a violent
marriage
she should stay in it because divorce
makes the children unhappy this is a
conservative folks
a pro-family conservative we will talk
about it
and lastly
u.s military-run slot machines earn a
hundred million dollars per year
from service members overseas
the us military is now running
casinos this is not a new thing
i had no idea that this was going on
but we will talk about it on today's
bonus show how do you get access to the
bonus show it's very easy you go to
joinpakman.com
and you use the coupon code if you want
big voting 22
if you want okay up to you you don't
have to take the discount on tomorrow's
program i will be joined by roger reeves
and then on thursday i will be joined by
professor paul slovik who does really
really interesting research
on cognitive biases heuristics
risk value calculation it sounds boring
but
i find it extraordinarily interesting so
i'm looking forward to that that as well
bonus show today
shows all week live streams upcoming no
shortage of things happening thank you
to everybody
you